Welcome everyone to today's major symposium on
extrachromosomal DNA.
It's a huge pleasure to chair this session.
My name is Anton Henson. I'm a physician scientist from Berlin, and it's really a
pleasure to do this session together with my co-speakers, Peter Lai
and Howard Chang, who
have really shaped our view
on ecDNA over the past couple of years.
I'm waiting for slide. Yeah.
So the session is called Beyond Chromosomes, Mechanisms, Consequences,
and Therapeutic Opportunities of Extrachromosomal DNA.
And I'd like to start this with an overview, a very simple one,
with basically two cells.
They are both dividing, and one of them is following the
classical rules of inheritance and the other is not.
As you can see on the right, extrachromosomal DNA
violates one of the most fundamental principles of inheritance
during mitosis, in that it distributes randomly to daughter cells,
and through that process is able to fuel intracellular
variance in a way that is otherwise not possible.
And we'll hear today how we can not only observe this now in cells,
but we can measure it at scale and using
some new algorithms that Howard will talk about.
And we now know that extrachromosomal DNA is not a rare event.
It's actually something that we can observe across different cancers in adult
cancers and pediatrics alike. And this is a figure from a review
that came out two days ago in "Cell," as part of a special
issue on the hallmarks of cancers that was written by Howard, Paul, and others
in the field
that really shows you how widely we can find ecDNA nowadays.
But we also come to realize that ecDNA is a moving target.
It's quite dynamic. There are catastrophic events that can lead to their
generation.
Many structural variants occur, and you'll see tomorrow a talk on ecDNA
fusions.
And all of this really leads to quite disrupted oncogene
expression.
And we're also learning more and more on the inheritance
patterns, as you'll see later. All of this
just contributes to how ecDNA drives
tumor progression.
And
all of this
really shows how it touches on so many different parts of the hallmarks of cancer.
And so we believe that ecDNA is really
a systems-level driver of cancer.
But in order to do so, it needs to actually be maintained in a cell.
And so you'll hear from Howard Chang on how certain retention
elements guarantee that ecDNA are retained within the cell.
In my talk, I'll talk to you about what happens when this doesn't go right
and when ecDNA leaves the nucleus and goes into micronuclei.
In Peter Lai's talk, you'll actually hear about
how this is not the end of the story and how micronuclei
can be transferred from one cell to the next through cell-to-cell
contacts.
So you'll really get a snapshot today on different parts of a life cycle of an
extrachromosomal DNA.
And at the end, we'll also touch on how this is relevant clinically and how we
might go about this therapeutically.
So with this, I'd like to introduce the first speaker of today, Peter Lai
from UT Southwestern. Thank you, Peter.
All right. Thank you very much to the organizers and to Anton for chairing this
session.
Okay, so my name is Peter Lai, and today I'm going to talk to you about some
emerging work from my lab which is currently unpublished, but hopefully, will
be published within the next month or so.
And so my laboratory is generally interested in the mechanisms and consequences of
genomic instability in the context of cancer development.
And so today I'm going to tell you about a catastrophic process that can give rise
to extrachromosomal DNAs or ecDNAs.
And so this is commonly referred to as chromothripsis, which is a Greek term for
chromosome shattering. And this was discovered by cancer genome sequencing
efforts over a decade ago. And so what they had initially
hypothesized from the current models of chromothripsis is that you start off
with an intact chromosome that undergoes some type of chromosome shattering event
to give rise to a number of different chromosome
fragments. These chromosome fragments are then subsequently repaired by the
cell's intrinsic DNA repair machinery and then put back together in the wrong order
to generate a derivative chromosome that's characterized by complex
rearrangements with segments that are now juxtaposed next to
segments that don't normally appear next to each other.
Some of these fragments also fail to participate in the religation event and also
can become lost to the cell and of a particular importance to this
session, some of these fragments can also circularize to give rise to
extrachromosomal DNA elements that we all know can harbor oncogenes and
genes that confer drug resistance.
And so typically from whole genome sequencing, the way that we would interpret
these types of
events is by looking at these copy number plots.
So this is an example where one chromosome is plotted from one end of the
chromosome to the other end, for a diploid chromosome sits at a copy number state
of two.
And after a chromothripsis event, you would now see a number of structural variants
that connects random pieces of the chromosome together, and this can also result in
loss of copy numbers when fragments are deleted, as well as
extrachromosomal DNA elements that get amplified to tens to hundreds of copies.
And this is a very simplistic overview of how we can see these events, and here's
one example from the original chromothripsis paper from Peter Campbell and
colleagues back in 2011. And so in this example, you can see a
chromothripsis event affecting chromosome 5, in which there are
a number of structural variants that connects different parts of the chromosome
together, probably about a couple dozen here or so, as well as
an oscillation in DNA copy number state in which it oscillates back and forth
between regions of the chromosome that are retained in this top copy number state
and then regions of the chromosome that are deleted from this bottom copy number
state. And if we zoom out and take a look at this particular example
in a genome-wide view, we can see that chromothripsis for this particular
chromosome is the sole site of genetic abnormality, which really raised the
question of how do these events arise
on a specific chromosome, whereas the rest of the genome is practically
spared?And so shortly after the discovery of
chromothripsis, several groups
began to propose that chromosome segregation defects during mitosis could be one
initiating event in driving chromothripsis.
So here's an example of a cell entering mitosis.
Chromosomes are aligned at the metaphase plate, and one particular chromosome is
now missegregated and improperly aligned.
And when this cell enters anaphase, this chromosome now gets missegregated into
this abnormal nuclear structure called the micronucleus.
And this was a very attractive hypothesis for chromothripsis at the time because
now you can spatially isolate a single chromosome away from the primary genome,
where it presumably acquires DNA damage.
And indeed, in 2015, David Pelman and colleagues combined live cell
imaging with single-cell DNA sequencing to demonstrate that the daughter cells
from a mother cell with a micronucleus can in fact acquire the signatures of
chromothripsis that we see in cancer genomes.
Of particular importance to this session, they also detected the
presence of circular DNA structures from single-cell DNA sequencing data.
And at the time, it was sort of unclear whether these represented bona fide
ecDNAs or double minute chromosomes, and whether they were stably
maintained within these genomes.
So my group has established a method to study
mechanisms underlying chromothripsis using a targeted chromothripsis approach in
which we can induce the missegregation of a specific human chromosome into
micronuclei at very high frequency.
And so I won't go into the details on how this works, but essentially we can take
human DLD1 colon cancer cells, and we can turn off the Y chromosome
centromere using this combination of these two drugs.
And so when we add doxycycline and auxin to these cells, the Y centromere is
turned off, and now we have an enrichment of these Y chromosome-specific
micronuclei that we can detect by DNA FISH.
Additionally, if we now propagate clones after inducing its
formation into micronuclei, we can see that under control conditions, this is what
a normal Y chromosome would look like.
And I forgot to mention that we also use CRISPR editing to insert a selection
marker specifically into the Y chromosome, and it's positioned here.
And after a chromothripsis event, this is now what it would look like.
So you would have a series of rearrangements as well as copy number changes
that's very reminiscent of what we typically see in human cancers.
Here's another example of clones that we can derive in which we see that the
cell essentially lost the entire Y chromosome except for
this particular fragment that sits right at the position where the neomycin
resistance gene is located. And so it's now amplified to a higher copy
number state, and if we use DNA
probes to look at these on mitotic chromosomes, we can see indeed that they are
now localized to ecDNAs, and they also become amplified
manyfold within these cells. And by whole genome sequencing, we can also
reconstruct the sequence of these events in which this
ecDNA, which is about 900 kilobases in size, was
originated from the ligation of two distinct fragments derived from the Y
chromosome at this particular location.
So this was the first experimental evidence that a chromothripsis event mediated
by micronuclei can in fact give rise to stable ecDNAs that can then
become propagated and amplified.
So using the system that I had just described to you, another cool thing about it
is that we can now look at mitotic chromosomes right after we induce
micronuclei, and we can recapitulate the sequence of events that leads to
chromothripsis. In this example, this is a Y chromosome that had now shattered into
multiple fragments, and you can see the fragments here lit up
by the green FISH probes. And we've used this system now to make several
discoveries about how chromothripsis arises.
For example, under-replicated chromosomes typically undergo mitotic cleavage by
this SLX4-XPF-ERCC1 endonuclease to shatter
or fragment the chromosome during mitosis.
And once the
chromosome has fragmented, these fragments are now held together by this protein
complex, and they segregate asymmetrically via this
clustering mechanism. However, some of these fragments can also fail to participate
in this clustering and also mislocalize to the cytoplasm at the exit
of mitosis.
And so one question that graduate student Liz Murray wanted to ask in my
laboratory is, beyond generating cell-intrinsic genomic alterations and
rearrangements, can micronuclei also impact nearby
cells? And so to address this, she started with RPE1 cells,
which are non-transformed cells.
She labeled DNA with the fluorescent dye called SirDNA and then
induced micronucleation using a combination of mitotic inhibitors.
And so I'm going to let this video play, and you're going to see the cells moving
around as cells normally do. And what really caught our attention is that
oftentimes these cells would form these long-stretched protrusions between these
two adjacent cells. And if we look at the DNA stain, we can see the presence of
this DNA stain that seemingly passages through this tube-like connection.
And although we didn't really understand at the time when we saw this what exactly
those were, looking in the literature, these are now referred to as tunneling
nanotubes, which have been described in a variety of physiological and disease
contexts.
And these tunneling nanotubes typically transport various types of cytoplasmic
cargo, including proteins, organelles, and RNA.
But whether DNA can serve as a substrate for transfer has not been
demonstrated. And if this was correct, this would sort of serve as the first
experimental evidence of a horizontal gene transfer-like mechanism
that's occurring in human cells.
In order to better visualize this, we wanted to arrest the cells from
migration and to stop moving around.
So we added this cytochalasin D, which is an actin inhibitor.
And when we do this, the cells immediately begin to constrict, and what really
caught our attention was that the cells that had already formed nanotubes continue
to maintain those nanotubes, such as here.
And if you look closely, you could also see the transport of these bulky
cytoplasmic cargo between these two adjacent cells between these nanotubes.
And if we now take the cells and fix them at a particular time and then
stain them for microtubules, we can see that these nanotubes are comprised of
different components of the mammalian cytoskeleton that forms this sort of
intricate network between cells in
culture.So now we combine these different
conditions together, and we can include
this DNA dye, and we can also induce micronuclei formation.
And we can indeed see the presence of these SIRH DNA labeled DNAs
passaging through these nanotube-like structures.
And from measuring the speed of this transfer, it seems to be
consistent with the transport of bulky cargo by molecular motors.
Additionally, these events are stimulated by induction of mitotic errors.
And importantly, these nanotubes are not induced by genomic instability or
having the micronuclei. So they form essentially spontaneously from direct
cell-cell contact.
And so now we're no longer going to use the cytoclazin D, so we can look at cells
in their intact native state. And if we take these cells and we stain them for the
cytoskeletal markers, tubulin and actin, we can see these stretched protrusions
between these cells. And if we use a different DNA stain called YoYo1, we can see
this large bulky micronucleus or piece of DNA
trapped here between these two tubes, or between these two cells within this
tube. And so what we think is happening is that a
genomically unstable cell with micronuclei could potentially
form nanotubes connections with these recipient cells, where the DNA can then
passage through this nanotube if the DNA was present in the cytoplasm.
And in order to really test this, we began to label distinct population of cells
with different markers. So here we're taking one set of cells, and we're labeling
them with histone H2B-GFP and another set with histone
H2B-RFP in red. And so now we can combine these two
cells together in co-culture experiments and then
perform microscopy. And what you're going to see is a green micronucleus at the
bottom of the screen coming up, and it's going to transfer over to that cell with a
red nucleus. And so the two cells now migrate apart, and it seems that this green
piece of DNA is now part of this red cell.
And so these were examples of DNA transfer between
the same RPE1 to RPE1 cell.
And now we can also do this in very different contexts.
We can take cells derived from the kidney.
So these are renal proximal tubule epithelial cells cultured
with RPE1 cells, so derived from different tissues.
And we also see these similar types of intercellular DNA transfer events,
suggesting that they're not restricted to individual cell types.
Next, in order to see this in a little bit more detail, we also labeled the
plasma membrane using this CAAX targeting motif
labeled with a halo tag. And so here you can see this long, stretched thin
protrusion between these two different cells.
And then now you can see the presence of this H2B-GFP labeled chromatin moving
from this donor cell to this RFP labeled recipient
cell.
We see this, and so after the DNA transfers, if we were then to
fix the cells, this is sort of what it would look like.
So these are examples of what we refer to as mismatched labeling
between the nuclei and micronuclei.
And so here, for example, is a kidney epithelial
cell labeled with histone H2B mCherry in which its nucleus is
red. And now it harbors this micronucleus or a fragment of DNA
that presumably arose from a neighboring kidney cell
expressing H2B-GFP. And we can see this also under very different
conditions. So for example, if we induce micronuclei using
depletion of mitotic checkpoint proteins to inactivate the mitotic
checkpoint, we can also do this and
arrest the cells in mitosis for a brief period using a
microtubule polymerization inhibitor, and then
release them from this arrest and allow them to form mitotic errors.
And we can also see similar types of DNA transfer events.
Additionally, this is not limited to just mitotic errors.
So if we induce DNA damage using variety of means,
so for example, if we use Cas9 to induce a DNA double strand break
specifically on the short arm of chromosome 3, this would generate chromosome
3p containing micronuclei. And we can also see similar types of DNA
transfer events between these co-cultured and
distinctly labeled cells. We can also hit cells with ionizing radiation to
induce DNA damage on a genome-wide level and also induce
DNA transfer. And then just to give you a sense of how often this
occurs, this is one way that we've begun to measure
this. So here we're taking RPE1 cells, treat them up with mitotic inhibitors.
And under these conditions, approximately 30% of cells has at least one
micronucleus. And if we now look at all of those micronuclei and ask what
fraction have this mismatched labeling, about 4% of those have a mismatched
label, suggesting that DNA transfer occurs at a low yet
measurable rate across many different cell types, many different
conditions. And it's also dependent on cell-to-cell contact.
So for example, if we culture cells and we reduce the density of cell
culture in order to prevent direct cell-cell contact, we can essentially
eliminate this event. And if we also use a filter to block the two different cells
from coming into direct contact, we can also inhibit DNA transfer.
So after the DNA goes into the recipient cell, it makes its way into the cytoplasm,
and we next wondered what happens to that piece of DNA after
that. So when the
recipient cell with the transferred DNA fragment enters the next mitosis,
its nuclear envelope disassembles, and the chromosomes begin to condense.
And what we see is that the transferred DNA fragments here labeled in different
colors from the native chromosomes
essentially rejoins the host chromosomes during mitosis, and they
can either be aligned with the host chromosomes, for example, here are examples
from metaphase as well as anaphase, or they can also be misaligned
as well. And so these are essentially fragments of DNA that either
contain or do not contain a human centromere.
So after it reincorporates into the host genome, the next question we wanted to ask
was whether these events can give rise to stable and functional
DNAs within that recipient cell population.
And so to test this, we went back to that system that I had described earlier in
which we can turn off the Y chromosome centromere and induce its formation in a
micronuclei. And then just to remind you, we also use CRISPR editing to
insert a neomycin resistance marker into this chromosome.
And so now the experiment that we really wanted to do was ask if we co-culture male
cells with Y chromosome containing this selection marker
in a micronucleus with female cells, can the female cells
eventually take up fragments of the Y chromosome and become resistant to the
drug that
this selection marker confers resistance
to?And so to test this, we performed a
series of experiments, and it's a little bit complicated, but I'm going to try to
walk you through it. And so here we took these male donor cells with the
Y-encoded neomycin resistance gene.
These cells are labeled in green, and we co-cultured these with female recipient
cells with a different set of selection markers and also a different fluorophore.
So they're labeled with their red.
And we co-cultured these two cells.
We added these two drugs, doxycycline and auxin, to trigger the missegregation of
the Y chromosome into micronuclei, specifically in the male
cells. And what we had hoped for is that then this fragment or the chromosome would
then transfer over to this female recipient cell.
So we then co-selected these cells with two different antibiotics, one
encoded from the male donor cell, one encoded by the female recipient cell.
And in the end, we're left with surviving cells that are comprised of
several different possibilities.
The first are green male cells that became spontaneously resistant to
this selection marker in the female cells.
This actually doesn't really happen, so we'll just ignore that.
The next possibility are these red and green cells.
So these actually represent male-to-female cell-cell fusion events,
which is sort of predicted if you co-select cells and force them to
survive. And then the third possibility are these mCherry positive cells.
So these are female recipient cells that had now became resistant
to the gene that was encoded on the Y chromosome in the male cells.
And so when we do this and look at the cell populations by flow cytometry, we can
see that under control conditions without induction of Y chromosome micronuclei,
most of these events give rise to these cell-cell fusion events as we had
expected. However, if we now induce Y chromosome-specific
micronuclei, this actually shifts from cell-cell fusion events to favor a
lot more of these mCherry labeled cells that now became resistant.
And this is the quantification down here.
And importantly, when we look at the different
mitotic chromosomes from all of these different control conditions,
almost all of them showed evidence of genome doubling between the
male donor and the female recipient genomes.
So they essentially became "tetraploid."
And we also see a small fraction of this in that population of cells in which we
expect the transfer to occur. But importantly, we also see this
subpopulation here that has a chromosome content that matches exactly
that of the female recipient genome.
And so we suspect that these
cells now harbor fragments of the Y chromosome, encoded neomycin
resistance gene, and then these female recipient cells that had taken up that
DNA became resistant to this drug, suggesting that they have now
this new function after inheriting this piece of DNA.
And to really look at this in more detail, we looked at these mitotic chromosome
spreads, and we used different types of DNA FISH probes to look for where are these
DNAs now located in the female genome.
And so these are female metaphase chromosomes, and we can see using
different FISH probes as well as these oligo paint
probes, that these transfer DNA fragments now manifest as
a single copy extra chromosomal DNA within these recipient cell
genomes.
And lastly, in order to demonstrate that these fragments indeed are
transcriptionally active in the recipient cell, we performed single-cell RNA
sequencing, and what this really showed us was that among those mCherry
positive cells, there's this distinct cluster of cells that are characterized
by high levels of the neomycin resistance gene and also a
nearby adjacent Y chromosome-encoded gene that's now being expressed in the
female cells. And we know these are female cells because they lack expression of
these male-specific markers,
suggesting that these fragments, once they've transferred over, are fully
functional, transcriptionally active, and can confer a new phenotype to these
recipient cells.
Okay, so here's the current model of this.
So
after
DNA damage or mitotic errors, this can cause the mislocalization of
genomic DNA to the cytoplasm, indicated here by the presence of
this micronucleus. These two cells, they migrate as part of their
normal nature, and then they come together and come into direct contact,
which then initiates the formation of these nanotube connections between the two
cells.
And then the DNA is now able to transport through this nanotube, enter the
recipient cell, and after the next mitosis and even in subsequent cell
divisions, is now
stably maintained within the recipient cell genomes for
months, actually. And when we showed that these
heritable extra chromosomal DNAs are also transcriptionally
active and can confer new cellular functions to this recipient
cell. And so in just the last couple of seconds, I want to talk about why does this
actually matter. So I think if this is correct, which we
are strongly confident that it is, it really challenges the assumption that
somatic genomes evolve as cell-autonomous units.
Instead, we show here that genomic alterations can also arise through
non-cell-autonomous mechanisms,
and that DNA transfer could represent an unrecognized source of somatic
aneuploidy and also megabase scale-sized DNA copy number
alterations. And then transferred DNA fragments can circularize and
become propagated and potentially amplified in the right context
as ecDNA.
And then in the tumor microenvironment, genomically unstable cancer cells could
potentially disseminate or propagate oncogenes or mutations to
nearby neighboring non-cancer cells.
And so these are exciting lines of direction that my laboratory is now
directly pursuing.
Okay, so with that, I would really like to thank the members of my lab.
So Elizabeth Murray is a graduate student who primarily drove
this work. We have a number of outstanding collaborators from researchers across
the world, as well as our sources of funding. And thank you very much.
Thank
you, Peter.
Any questions?
Raul? Yeah.
Hey, Peter. Great work. Really interesting.
Have you thought about how we could quantify the rate
at which this process might happen in
human samples, in particular human tumor samples?
Like, are there technologies or approaches you can think of?
Because it's-
One question I would have is that a random piece of DNA wouldn't really have
much function, right? So it would only matter if the DNA had an actual
gene or something on it. So how do you think we could quantify-
Right
... the rate?
Yeah. That's a fantastic question.
So I think, most of the DNA transfer events probably does
happen at a low frequency, and it doesn't give rise to much because
depending on what sequences are transferred.
But I think in the right context, so for example, if the right mutation
transfers to another cell, then that could potentially then become
propagated in the presence of a positive selection.
And how can we quantify this? So this is something that my lab has been thinking
about really hard. We haven't come up with a really concrete way to do this yet,
because one of the main challenges is that if you're thinking about an individual
tumor, they essentially share the same SNPs.
So it's really difficult to distinguish between donor-derived DNA
versus recipient cell DNA, right?
And so now we're thinking about different ways where we can experimentally model
this and use sequences that are more amenable to tracking
in the laboratory. And then in the context of actually measuring this
directly in tumors, we're still thinking about that.
But I think it really will rely on new computational techniques to
discriminate between these types of events.
And one way we've been thinking about it is by tracking mutations
between clones or actually DNA copy number alterations between clones
that arise at different times within the same tumor, and using that to infer
whether it was
transferred or not. But that's a really good question.
I don't have the best solid answer at this moment, though.
Peter, quick suggestion. Have you thought about
the context of leukemias? There are hematopoietic stem cell transplantations
happening. Have you thought about-
Absolutely
... looking at samples of those and to see if leukemia cells from the host
and the grafts could be exchanged?
Yeah, absolutely. So one really good example of that are, for example, Fanconi
anemia patients who had undergone
blood transplantations, where you could potentially look for donor-derived
DNA sequences and SNPs present in the donor DNA but not in the
patient DNA. So that's an excellent suggestion.
One more question.
Question.
Sure.
Peter, great talk, and it's an amazing discovery.
So in each case, is DNA damage required
in order to induce this transfer? And in that case, do you think that we're
accelerating this process when we treat patients with
chemotherapy and potentially provoking secondary malignancies?
Absolutely. So in the normal context, the genomic DNA is
confined to the nucleus. So it's protected from being
transferred. But if you have now DNA that's mislocalized in the cytoplasm, for
example, after DNA damage, after mitotic errors, now it's an
environment where it could then be permissive for undergoing
transfer.
And the question you're asking about whether we're inducing these events with
chemotherapy is something that we're actually trying to test right now in the
laboratory. So we're trying to determine whether DNA transfer occurs in
vivo if you hit tumor cells with either chemotherapy
or radiotherapy. Yeah.
One last question. Howard, do you want to ask something?
Peter, great talk. My question is whether you think the recipient
cell would have its cGAS-STING pathway activated and therefore
essentially reject the transferred DNA.
And if so, then is this mechanism really restricted to just transfer between
tumor cells?
Yeah. Excellent question. So we don't have direct experimental evidence for
it, but we do think that once it transfers into the recipient cell,
it could then potentially activate the cGAS-STING pathway.
However, we do show that both lamin-containing and
non-lamin-containing DNAs both transfer.
So whether one activates the pathway more strongly than the other, we don't really
know yet.
But we do think that there are potentially pathways that exist to suppress these
events. So, for example, in addition to DNA sensors, one can
also think about cytoplasmic nucleases that could potentially degrade the
DNA once it transfers, or even in the donor cell before it transfers.
But we're still currently trying to understand what are the molecular
mechanisms that regulate these type of processes in both cancer and
non-cancer settings. Yeah.
Peter, fantastic talk.
Thank you.
I'll hand over to Howard Chang now with the next talk.
Thank you, Anton. Good afternoon.
I'm delighted to be here and share some of the progress from our laboratory.
May I have my first slide, please?
Okay. These are my disclosures.
Cancer patients really face a daunting challenge when the cancers contain
extrachromosomal DNA. As you've heard, these are really prevalent
problems that affect both adults and children, men and women.
These are, as we've described, large circular pieces of
DNA that encode oncogenes, regulatory elements, and additional
elements. They are large in the sense that they are 100 kb to a
megabase.
But what I want to talk to you today is really on three important
advances. First, our increasing understanding of how
oncogenes gain a transcriptional advantage on ecDNAs.
Secondly,
how ecDNAs allow rapid genome change, yet retain
the capacity to be passed on through multiple
somatic generations in the cancer cell.
And finally, how this kind of unusual mechanism of
inheritance allows us to identify ecDNAs and their
unique roles in cancer and to improve cancer
diagnostic. And of course, this is a therapeutic vulnerability that we hope to
exploit on top of, because they're not found in normal cells.
All right, so let's dig in. As we start studying extrachromosomal DNA,
one of the first really, I think, surprising and beautiful
discoveries is that they congregate in these dynamic hubs.
When you hear about ecDNAs existing in 10 or maybe even 100
copies in a cancer cell-They don't actually show up in
100 separate dots. We discovered, and we and others, that in
fact they often concentrate into these micron size hubs
where dozens or more ecDNAs come into close physical proximity.
They're held together by specific proteins such as transcriptional machinery,
co-activators such as BRD4, and that if you block
the roles of these proteins, that ecDNAs fly apart, and in
fact, their transcriptional advantage stops.
So this led to a view that these extrachromosomal DNA hubs are
the unit of oncogene function. And what we learned is that inside
these ecDNA hubs, there is a new mode of transcription called
intermolecular gene activation.
So normally in a long piece of chromosome, you have genes and your
DNA regulatory elements on the same molecule.
And these regulatory elements are the switches that decide when and where these
genes turn on and off. And the switches only from near proximity on the
same molecule can turn on the gene.
That inside this ecDNA hub, we can actually have
different molecules, where the enhancer from one
ecDNA actually turns on the gene, the coding sequence, of
a different ecDNA. And these ecDNAs can actually originally come from
different chromosomes. All right?
So basically, this allows a cooperative and combinatorial modes of gene
activation. These ecDNAs gain access to
enhancers that could normally never get at before, and thus
allows this massive transcription.
But this has additional consequences.
And that is that we believe that this will lead to potentially oncogene
diversification in several ways, as I'll show you, because of this kind of
interdependency, and this is, of course, another therapeutic target.
One of the first most direct examples is when we first had the ability
to isolate individual ecDNAs biochemically and
subject them to single molecule or long-read sequencing.
And we can see that in fact there's far more sequence diversity
among ecDNAs.
We oftentimes imagine ecDNAs as a full locus amplification, just a
gene, all its regulatory elements, and in pressing lots of copies, and we
definitely see that.
We also often see what is called enhancer hijacking.
Rearrangements that bring in another enhancer into proximity to
an ecDNA, allowing, let's say, more potent expression.
But we were surprised to see another phenomenon called ecDNA
specialization. This is a situation where you have a coding
sequence that's amplified, but no regulatory elements.
And other times you see focal enhancer amplification, but no
coding sequence.
Now, if you're making an expression construct in the lab and you ended up with
these kinds of results, you probably go back and try to make it again because
the dogma of molecular biology tells us that you wouldn't get gene expression.
But in fact, we see this in fact in patient samples and amplified to
quite high levels, as seen in the
TRACERx or the Genomes England dataset pioneered by
Chris Bailey and Charlie Swanson.
So we interpret this to really mean that there's intermolecular
complementation in the ecDNA hubs because these
enhancers can turn on these coding gene only sequences,
and therefore these kind of unique molecular species can
exist and be possibly selected for in cancer cells.
Okay.
Another really striking observation came from the work of Hyrum Yee, who's in the
audience, and that is the finding that ecDNAs have become a platform
for gene innovation through gene fusions.
We heard this morning about the advent of Gleevec targeting Philadelphia
chromosome, and that, of course, is targeting a gene rearrangement,
a fusion protein, BCR-ABL, now that happens on a chromosome.
And so in this work, pioneered by Hyrum and Shu Zheng, and together with Paul
Michiel, we found that in fact there's a very high rate of
structural variation on extrachromosomal DNAs, and that actually will lead
to gene fusions.
And so this is basically a single coding transcript that will now bring different
kind of elements together. They're actually, in fact, the most
prevalent form of sort of source of structural variants or gene
fusions in solid tumors. And one of the most prevalent one that we found
is one that combines the five prime N exon
one of a long non-coding RNA called PVT1 with
diverse oncogene partners on the three prime N.
And this has the consequence of increasing the
messenger RNA stability of any transcript
that's fused to this PVT1, so for example, MYC, a short-lived transcript,
and that enhances oncogene function.
And that there are actually many other sort of oncogenes that can be boosted in
this way. So think of the PVT1 exon one as a
universal five-prime UTR that basically enhances your RNA
stability.
So we think this is going to be a fruitful area of investigation.
And to summarize the concept, there's this fearsome Greek
monster, right? The mythology, the Chimera, that combines
these
monsters' different capabilities, and that's kind of what the ecDNA provides.
It's a platform for making these now altered transcripts with
enhanced molecular capabilities. Dr.
Hyrum Yee, who's in the audience, will be giving a talk on this topic in the
mini symposium tomorrow afternoon.
So please go check it out if you find this interesting.
The
second major challenge I think ecDNA faces is its mitotic
transmission. As Anton and Peter both described,
ecDNAs lack centromeres. And so you can imagine that with
every cell division, this is a mortal challenge to its
propagation. And what we've learned, we and others have seen for
decades, is that extrachromosomal DNAs, in this case labeled in green,
will basically attach to mitotic chromosomes labeled in purple here.
And as the chromosome segregates, the ecDNA basically will hitch a ride
into the resulting daughter cells.
This is called mitotic hitchhiking.This is a phenomenon that also
is seen with DNA viruses that don't have centromeres.
But the question is, how does this happen? What is the molecular mechanism?
So we imagine that there must be some sort of special sequence that allows
ecDNAs and a machinery to attach to mitotic chromosomes.
So two very talented graduate students,
Venkat Sankar and King Hong, devised this new strategy that we call
Retain-seq to identify potential retention elements.
This strategy starts by taking human genomic DNA,
fragmenting them into small pieces, and including them into
a heterologous plasmid
and asking, would any of these sequences allow this plasmid,
upon transfection in multiple passages, to be
retained and therefore, basically,
proportionally amplified over time.
Okay, so then when you sequence this in the DNA, the input
genome-specific sequences might be retained and therefore elevated.
And this strategy proved successful.
It's an unbiased approach, and we discover a family of
actually thousands of these retention elements that are present on
ecDNAs. And this is an example showing that, in fact, their mechanism
is by enhancing retention. So we have these
cells where we have basically lacO array to allow imaging of the
ecDNA. We can have it in a naked fashion or add the retention
element. And if you transfect
the plasmid, we can then watch over time by labeling the
lacO with associated proteins, whether these ecDNAs are
basically attached to the mitotic chromosomes or perhaps are actually
detached if they lack the retention elements.
And what we found is that a single retention element basically
halves the rate of failure. Right?
So basically increase your chance for retention by at least 50%.
And this can be imaged basically through the entire time
through mitosis. And this is a endogenous ecDNA.
And what we also learned is that having multiple retention elements
sequentially improves the efficacy to over 95%.
And so this will have a very significant potential impact.
Okay. We also went in and delved into the molecular mechanism
of what are these sequences and where do they attach to.
And this then involves using a classic technology that's called chromosome
confirmation capture or Hi-C to map the contact points between the
retention elements and their chromosomal anchoring sites.
What we learned is that there's actually a very interesting logic to this
retention, and that is that these retention elements comprise of
specific classes of promoters, gene promoters that
allow transcription. And these bookmark sites, that's the places where the
ecDNA is attached to, are actually enhancers
where they interact. So in a
way, these mitotic retention, right, recapitulates
enhancer-promoter contact that happens in normal chromosome gene
expression, except this happens in interphase and mitotic
retention happens in M phase. Moreover, there's something very
special. It is not that
every promoter enhancer can be a retention element, but that
there are specific sites in the genome that
retain their accessibility and activity.
So during mitosis, their chromosomes condense 10,000-fold, but
only a special subset of sites retain accessibility.
So this is called mitotic bookmarking.
So these mitotic bookmark sites are massively enriched, 150-fold
plus enriched as retention elements.
So we understand that this retention activity is hacking
into exploiting this endogenous mechanism of mitotic
bookmarking, which allows gene transcription memory to get
reactivated in the next cell cycle.
And this is the mechanism that these cells are hacking into.
Okay.
And finally, we performed mathematic modeling led by
Matt Jones to ask how important are these retention elements.
And so if you take, for example, ecDNAs with
very a potent selection factor, let's say a potent oncogene.
We can imagine that they would really confer cell growth.
But we can also imagine that if the ecDNAs can get lost with some probability
with every cell division, what is the likelihood of maintaining that
over multiple cell generations? Okay.
And the answer is that essentially you need something like a
95% or greater efficacy of retention to have any
chance of a long-term propagation of any kind of extrachromosomal DNA
element. And so this is in fact matching the kind of data
we observed with our experimental system.
And this is also demonstrating that if we specifically methylate, for
example, retention elements, we also then can kick out basically
extrachromosomal DNAs, and that would actually because they would turn off the eDNA
activity.
Okay, so I've told you then is that retention elements represent a
new element in molecular biology.
They give ecDNAs their immortal status.
And what's happening is that in addition to a
oncogene or other selection factor that gives a cell a growth advantage,
we need a retention element to allow their basically uninterrupted
propagation that will allow persistence and oncogene will provide the
selection. Without it, the ecDNAs will
oftentimes be lost through subsequent cell divisions.
So this is a key new aspect of eDNA biology that we
should hope to exploit.
Okay.
Now, finally, I want to turn to the question of cell-to-cell
variation
and our understanding of how we can understand detect ecDNAs.
What I've told you about so far about eDNA persistence is that there
is still random segregation into daughter cells, right,
even if they're retained. And this is an
opportunity for us to think about how we can understand and detect ecDNAs.
Because if you imagine just throwing dice or other kind of
games of chance, then we get this random inheritance and very high
variance and with a high mean, whereas a chromosomal
amplification would have a staple inheritance, so it would have a high mean and low
variance. And so Matt JonesA very talented
postdoc
realized this property that we can visualize both in
basically DNA FISH experiments, for example, in these colon cancer
cells, these ecDNA-containing cells with the DM.
You can see different variations, lots of copies here, very few here, so
big variance versus in a-- And when they're staple integrated, so-called
HSR, they have a very consistent, a much more consistent level of copy
number. Okay. So this idea
then is to create a classifier that we call
SCAMP, okay? And we can classify gene amplifications with
single-cell resolution by looking at this variation in the
copy number. And so
this is
essentially an AI
system that classifies the ecDNA class genes,
and we can basically then quantify whether this is an ecDNA positive
or a negative cell or in a subpopulation of cells, and this led to a number of sort
of potentially useful end results, for example, evolutionary analysis,
the phenotyping of the cells, and tracking ecDNA biology.
Okay. So let's just remember that we're looking at the variance of the
signal, not just the height of the signal, and this has certain advantages.
Okay.
So first of all, is that if we use simulated amplicons, we can see that
indeed, as the copy number goes up, the copy number
variance also goes up with ecDNAs, shown in red here.
And that, for example, with chromosomal amplification, the copy
number goes up, but the variance does not. So this is very clear.
But even when there's a mixture at a single-cell level, we can still
discern the populations that have these different characteristics.
And that translates into this high-level performance
on both simulations and cell lines.
You can see that basically the true
information's here in the upper right, and we can actually approach that quite
well. Okay. So I think the key advantage here is that you can really detect
basically current ecDNA status versus the history of ecDNA
presence. Because if we look at prior methods, for example,
Amplicon Architect, pioneered by Maneet Bathna, who's really a key
workhorse in the field,
we can see that, for example, in the chromosomal reintegration,
sometimes these will be classified as ecDNA because they went through the
history of ecDNA. But that single-cell variance is no
longer there, and so that they will be correctly classified now as
actually no longer ecDNA by this method, which we
call SCAMP. Okay? And so there are a number of these situations which we have
this perhaps improved insight into the current status
of ecDNA biology. Okay. And so indeed, if we
look at this confusion matrix, we'll see that we will do a good job
versus whole genome sequencing analyzed with Amplicon Architect.
You can see that, SCAMP does a good job with a
true and false, and the specific advantage here is basically
over a situation where there's a history of ecDNA, but they have reintegrated,
and this is now, we believe, picked up by SCAMP. All right?
And this is as seen in, for example, in a set of tumors analyzed in the
TCGA, actually performed in my lab,
and then you can see that, for example, in a similar situation where, for
example, in breast cancer, there's this history of ecDNA, but they have
reintegrated. They are now detected by whole genome sequencing, but in
fact, most of these are now HSRs or other kind of genomic
reintegration, and they're actually not ecDNAs.
And there's also the capacity to detect subclonal ecDNA
presence because you're looking at this cell-to-cell variation.
Okay.
So I'll show you an example how we can deconvolute a complex biology
of subclonal ecDNAs.
Forward. Okay. And so in this case of a
glioblastoma tumor that was analyzed in TCGA.
And so here, every row is actually
a single cell, and every column is basically a genomic locus.
We can see that, in fact, that there are four clusters of
single cells, and they're in fact cells.
This cluster three has ecDNAs for both MDM2 and MYC,
and where these other clusters have different kind of ecDNAs, just MDM2, and
this other cluster does not. And so if you pseudo bulk it together,
you can, for example, reconstruct the genomic amplicon, for example, for
cluster three. Okay. All right.
And this method is not limited to just genomic sequencing or
single-cell sequencing, but you can also use it for FISH images.
And so this is, for example, for FFPE, so clinical
samples.
So in this set, every column here, this is different sets of tumors, and we
can analyze by sequencing or by fluorescent in situ hybridization, so more
compatible with clinical data. And you can see that
these tumors with very high levels of both MYC and also very
high variance, right? And so, for example, and they're predicted to be ecDNAs.
And for example, you can see that this one, you see lots of copies, very few copies
right next to each other. This is consistent with an ecDNA pattern.
And you can actually apply this classifier to this particular
problem. And this is done by Natasha Weiser.
Okay, so I've told you then is that ecDNAs allow the
accelerated evolution of cancer cells, and this is really a key
factor of ecDNA biology. And one of those mechanisms
is as a source of gene fusions, where you can combine different genes
together to activate their activity.
Another key element to allow ecDNA immortality are these
retention elements that allow their persistence through multiple cell
cycles. And finally, a
new tool called SCAMP will help you identify ecDNAs with single-cell
resolution and distinguishing current status also versus past
history. So hope that'll be useful, and it's compatible also with
histology or FISH kind of samples.I want
to thank many people involved in this work, especially highlight the work
of Venkat and King on the
retention elements, the work of Matt and Natasha
on the SCAM, single cell detection, and Hai-Rim, I
briefly mentioned her work on the gene fusion.
And I want to thank all my colleagues, especially Paul Michiel, Anton,
many folks involved in the E-Dynamic team, and a grateful acknowledge for my
funding sources. And I want a special shout out to my partner in
crime, Paul Michiel. We did not coordinate actually our dress code, but we ended
up wearing the same blue shirt. So, this is maybe more a
commentary about men's fashion. Okay.
So I'm happy to take questions. Thank you so much.
Fantastic talk.
Marson?
Hi. Gorgeous data as always. I was wondering if you could
speculate on mechanisms of HSR formation, sort
of post an ecDNA phase. And classically, HSRs represent
very long, potentially multi-megabase tandem arrays of a
particular amplified segment. And
what is the sort of dynamics of how all those copies would hone
in on a single locus? And does it have to do with
the biology of maybe these retention elements, or are there other
mechanisms at play? Because to me, that seems like an extremely mysterious
transition.
Thank you for this very insightful question.
So I think this really speaks to the importance of ecDNA hub in the life
cycle of ecDNA. Because if you imagine that when I first learned about
these HSRs, homogeneous staining regions, you basically have
multiple copies of some sort of amplicon one after another.
And if you think they are independent events, it seems almost
unimaginable that multiple copies would jump into the exact
same spot in the genome. Okay? But if you think about
an ecDNA hub, there are dozens of copies already right
next to each other, and then a ray of, let's say, X-ray shoots it and just
breaks it, but they're all next to each other.
You can imagine that they might now reintegrate as a single
tandem sort of duplicated region. Right?
So I think that is one explanation for how that may
happen. You can obviously imagine there are other
related mechanisms like breakage bridge, fusion bridge, but this involves
obviously locally copying and breaking, and there are other kind of signatures
associated with that. So I think that the physical structure is
telling us something about the history of the genesis of
the genomic abnormality.
Just a quick follow-up there. Do you ever see...
Because one other possibility is that the small circles start becoming bigger
circles and sort of self-assembling maybe through these kind of cycles
through micronuclei. Is that something you observe as a sort of pre-HSR
phase?
We do see that because in the sense that when we started doing this
work on, I showed you that there's a way that we can actually, it's a method called
CRISPR-Cas, you can actually basically isolate ecDNAs and
separate them by size. The ecDNA is actually far more complex.
So for example, in Colo 320DM cells, it's not just a single
species, there's actually multiple kinds of
ecDNAs. So there are probably all kinds of rearrangements that's going on
basically within these ecDNA hubs.
Thanks.
Next question, please.
Thanks. A really wonderful presentation.
Thanks. And my question is,
it is possible that ecDNA actually is the
DNA that
has been observed in several circulating
extracellular vesicles in tumor?
Okay. The question is whether the ecDNA can be present in, it's basically
a cell-free DNA or
extracellular vesicles.
I think the answer is definitely is possible, and I think that because of their
high copy number. If you just think about
sensitivity of detection, you're going to detect something or anything at all,
maybe ecDNA should have a higher chance of being detected.
So I was really excited to see Peter's talk about intercellular
transfer. So obviously then, in that process, if it goes wrong, it could obviously
come out.
So, I think it's definitely possible.
One more question, please.
Hi, Howard. Thanks so much for a great talk.
This is a question about the hub formation.
So outside the context of the MYC or PVT1
associated ecDNA, do you see a lot of hub formation, for example, with the EGFR
ecDNA or FGFR2, for example?
I believe that we have observed some of these hubs with the Snu16
cell line that involve FGFR2 and maybe also
a little bit with the EGFR. The mechanisms that I
talked about, especially with like BRD4 and so forth, of course, much better
described for the MYC ecDNA, where a lot of the
transcriptional landscape of the enhancer has been well mapped.
Thank you.
Thank you very much, Howard.
Okay, this was a perfect segue into the next talk that I would like
to present to you, where I'll talk to you about what happens when the
retention of ecDNA goes wrong and when ecDNA leaves the nucleus, and
what the consequences are of that micronucleation.
First, disclosures.
And I'll start with a very simple slide that I already showed you in the
introduction, where you can see one cell that divides
and where ecDNA fails to tether or to hitchhike to chromosomes,
and would then end up into a micronucleus.
And we've known for decades that this can happen, but what we
fundamentally didn't understand so far isWhen this happens,
how this happens, and what contributes to this detachment, and what the
consequences are, most importantly, for the cells that inherit such micronuclei.
So in order to understand this better, Lotte Brückner in my lab, a very talented
PhD student, studied isogenic cell line pairs in which
an oncogene, such as MYC, EGFR, or MYC--
sorry. MYC, yeah,
are amplified either in a linear form in an HSR or
extrachromosomally. These are derived from different cancer entities, and
she asked the question, how often do we see such
amplicons outside the nucleus within a micronucleus?
And here on the right side, you can see that with regards to those
micronuclei that did not contain the amplicon, there was no difference to be
seen between cells with a linear or extrachromosomal amplification.
Suggesting that in general, chromosomal instability does not seem to be different
between those two cell types. But when looking at those
micronuclei that contain the amplicon sequence specifically, we could see a
significantly higher degree of micronucleation in those cells with ecDNA,
suggesting that there is some likelihood of ecDNA
hitchhiking to not work, and those ecDNA ending up
in micronuclei. But what I would like you to pay attention to
is that there's actually quite a lot of variability between different cell types
in the amount of those micronuclei suggesting that
retention capacity might be different between different cell types, and this will
be more important at the end of this talk.
So in order to understand whether the mere presence of ecDNA would
promote
the likelihood of their micronucleation, we teamed up with Andrea
Ventura, a part of our E-Dynamics Cancer Grand Challenges consortium at Sloan
Kettering, who has developed a really elegant model in which you can engineer
ecDNA using the Cre-Lox system.
And so he engineered mouse cells that either had MYC on
ecDNA or where MYC was expressed from a linear transgene.
And you can clearly see on the right side that only in the presence of an
MYC ecDNA,
we detect high degrees of micronucleation.
Again, suggesting that it's not just the expression level of the oncogene or
some sort of chromosomal instability, but the ecDNA
itself that
promotes this micronucleation.
Based on this, we thought that this was a stochastic process, and that just
randomly one or two ecDNA might fail to tether, might fail to be
retained as how it showed and would end up in a micronucleus.
But when using a system that was developed in Paul Michel's lab, where you can
track ecDNA using
fluorescence imaging, where the ecDNA contains a Tet-O array and
TetR mNeonGreen would label those ecDNA specifically, we observed something
interesting.
We saw that when ecDNA detached, they tended to form clusters of
ecDNA, and those clusters were inherited on average in one of the two
daughter cells and not both, and in one large micronucleus.
Suggesting that this process was asymmetric and was originating mostly from
clusters of ecDNA,
which suggests that there's a directed process underneath this detachment.
And this was a little bit reminiscent of
some of the chromatin fragments that you can see tethered together during
mitosis, so we asked, are these ecDNA maybe damaged?
And indeed, when looking for signs of DNA damage, those
clusters of ecDNA that detached
showed
heightened signs of DNA damage.
And so that has asked the question, well, is DNA damage actually responsible for
the detachment and clustering? In order to test that, we directed
CRISPR-Cas9 directly to the ecDNA and induced cuts on
ecDNA. As you can see here on the left side, this CRISPR guided cuts
led to the detachment and clustering of ecDNA that was damaged and
also caused them to micronucleate in one of the daughter cells.
Which indicates that really, DNA damage on ecDNA can promote that clustering,
detachment, and micronucleation.
And similar as seen as for other chromatin fragments that are
unrepaired in mitosis, which are held together as also Peter Lee
contributed importantly to by CIP2A, TOPBP1,
MDC1, those clusters of ecDNA were also associated with this
complex. And moreover, when disrupting this complex
through shRNA-mediated knockdown of each of those components, we saw a
clear dispersal of this cluster into single
ecDNA that would then form smaller micronuclei in both daughter
cells.
Which suggests that this
complex is really important for the clustering of ecDNA during
mitosis.
But what was not clear was whether or not this detachment
involved damaged chromatin fragments that would
co-segregate with ecDNA into a micronucleus, whether this was
only happening to one ecDNA species at a time,
or whether maybe non-homologous different ecDNA species would collectively go into
a micronucleus.
And to address this question, we really needed a new method that would sensitively
detect and quantify any type of DNA in single
micronuclei.
And in order to do this, Robin Xu, a very talented MD-PhD student in the lab,
developed a method that he termed single micronucleus and main nucleus
sequencing or MNM-seq, in which we laser
microdissect out both the micronucleus and the adjacent primary
nucleus, followed by sequencing and analysis.
And as you can imagine, this is quite a difficult task to do, but really gave
us some really interesting insights, not only into ecDNA
locations into the micronucleus, but also can now help us understand patterns
of chromosomal instability in general.
So applying this method to cell lines in which we know that different
ecDNA species exist,
Robin observed something quite interesting.
In the vast majority of cases, those micronuclei only contained
the ecDNA, and only very rarely that we see any chromatin
fragments.Not only were these chock-full with
Ecdna, but we saw that all different Ecdna species found in the
cell were found in the same micronucleus, suggesting that Ecdna
collectively might missegregate into micronuclei, which kind of was
also
similar to what had been observed in Ecdna hubs.
So we validated this using FISH. On the left side, you'll see a metaphase spread,
just to confirm to you that these are really independent, different Ecdna
structures that exist in the cell.
And on the right side, you'll see micronuclei that contained
all different Ecdna species within the same micronucleus.
And this raised another question, and the question was, well, is it
maybe that you don't need each Ecdna to be damaged, but maybe one
Ecdna will drag other Ecdna into the same micronucleus,
similar to what we see with Ecdna hubs?
And so one experiment we did to test this was to induce a cut in one
Ecdna and see what happens to another Ecdna species that's independent.
And to our surprise, we saw that this cut on one Ecdna-containing
MYC led to the co-missegregation of the other Ecdna
into the same micronucleus, whereas we never saw this
other Ecdna alone in a micronucleus.
That really suggests that it's not only the DNA damage, but maybe the signaling
involved or other factors that cluster Ecdna together that can
lead to collective Ecdna missegregation into the same micronucleus.
So to summarize, this new method of MN-seq allowed us to understand
that Ecdna, when damaged,
tends to missegregate collectively together with other non-homologous
sequences and independent of other chromatin fragments.
And so you may ask yourself now, well, this is all interesting, but how relevant is
this for the cell?
So in order to understand that, we went back to the system that was beautifully
established in Paul Michel's lab, and Aditi in his lab, a very talented
PhD student, looked at these cells over time and asked,
"Well, when a cell inherits a micronucleus, what happens to that cell?"
And what was really
quite remarkable was to see that those cells that inherited a micronucleus that
contained a lot of Ecdna behaved quite differently to other cells that either
didn't have a micronucleus or had a micronucleus of other content, in
that they stopped dividing, tended to undergo cell death, or
proliferated at much, much lower extent.
Which suggests that if Ecdna fails to
be retained in a cell and leaves the nucleus, this
has really important implications for cancer cell fitness.
In order to better understand whether this was also relevant in patients, we
set out to look for
micronucleation in different patient populations, all with different types of
oncogenes amplified on Ecdna,
to ask, well, how often does this happen there?
And quite strikingly, what I showed you at the beginning with cell lines, this was
quite exaggerated in patients. Here we saw on the one hand that there was
higher micronucleation rate in patients with Ecdna, but
the variance of micronucleation rate was quite high between different patients.
Some patients almost behaved like, or cancers behaved like
cancers without Ecdna, and some had almost no cells that
didn't have micronucleus with Ecdna, suggesting there was really a huge
heterogeneity when it comes to the retention capacity or the likelihood of Ecdna
to be lost from a nucleus in those cancers.
And that raised the question whether this would impact cancer cell fitness,
and therefore the cancer aggressiveness in general.
But in order to address that question, we needed a homogenous population of
patients that all had the same Ecdna with the same
oncogene, and for which we had clinical data from diagnosis over
the course of treatment, and for which we could establish
the micronucleation tendency at diagnosis prior to
treatment. So we collected hundreds of neuroblastoma patients for which we
know that MYCN is the most
commonly amplified oncogene on Ecdna, and found 86
patients for which all of those were on Ecdna, and for which
we knew that all of those got the same standard of care treatment over time,
and where we had samples at diagnosis prior to any treatment.
And again, Lotte stratified those into those
cells with or without micronuclei and asked the question whether
Ecdna was found within them.
And
remarkably, we found that when Ecdna tended to be in the micronucleus
in those cancers, those patients did much better than
patients in which either micronuclei were found but didn't contain any
Ecdna, or those patients without any micronuclei.
Which really suggests that this cell biological phenomenon that we saw in vitro
not only translates to impaired cell fitness on a cellular level,
but seems to also impact the aggressiveness of this tumor
in patients over time.
And looking at these Kaplan-Meier curves, this was really addressing one
fundamental old question that we had in
the field of neuroblastoma research, which was that all MYCN amplified
neuroblastomas had been known for decades to
be very aggressive. And actually, neuroblastoma is one of the first
entities in which MYCN amplification on Ecdna was used to
stratify patients because we knew that this was an aggressive phenotype.
But clinically, we always observed a couple of patients that did better than
others, and we couldn't find any genetic evidence that would give us a
stratification of those patients that would perform better under treatment than
others. And we believe that now, looking at
Ecdna kind of retention
or their extranuclear
existence may help us to stratify those patients.
But not only that, if you look at those curves, you might imagine that maybe
we can now devise therapies that would force Ecdna
to be lost in mitosis, going into micronuclei, and maybe we could
make those patients behave more like the patients that have a lot of Ecdna in
micronuclei.So in order to address that question, we
collaborated with a company called Econic Biosciences which I
co-founded and is based in London, and found inhibitors that
would disrupt ecDNA tethering to a great extent, as seen here on the left
side. We see all this ecDNA detaching from chromosomes.
And so when we applied this inhibitor to patient-derived xenografts that either had
the same amplicon amplified on an ecDNA or an
HSR, same tumor entity, and treated those patient-derived
xenograft models with this inhibitor, we saw drastic tumor regressions
only in the context of ecDNA. But in the context of
intrachromosomal amplifications, this did not seem to change the tumor's
behavior to the same extent. Which really suggests that
ecDNA
retention is a therapeutically actionable liability
of those cancers, which we think we should exploit more in the future.
So with this, I'd like to summarize what I talked to you about today, and that is
that the retention elements and the retention of ecDNA we know is
important for ecDNA to be immortal.
But not only that, we also know that if ecDNA is not
retained and failed to retain, it's not only that they will be lost, as Howard
showed, but if they're lost and go outside the
nucleus and go into a micronucleus, this impacts cells'
fitness in that they divide less, undergo cell death more
often, and this translates to differences in patient survival, which we think we
can now
address therapeutically.
With this, I'd like to end and thank all the people involved, especially Lotte
Brückner, Robin Xu from my lab, but also Ivy, Xu, Aditi, and many
more from Paul's and Howard's group who were essential to get
this project going. As you can see, we went
from in vitro cell experiments all the way
to patient
data, which wouldn't have been possible without the support from Cancer Grand
Challenges and the entire team, eDynamic.
I hope I've mentioned most of the people that were involved.
Many others here in the room also clearly helped, such as Roel Verhaak and others.
And, yeah, without that team, this wouldn't have been possible.
So really, thank you to those. Thank you very much, and I look forward to your
questions.
Carol.
Thanks, Anton. That was really terrific.
I wanted to know for your patient samples,
I'm trying to understand the difference from some of the talks that I've heard
earlier.
Neuroblastoma patients typically are P53 wild type.
So do you think that the P53 status is impacting the fact that you see
that the ecDNA is associated under our
current therapies with a better prognosis, the retention of it?
Yeah. So this is a great question. So actually, as you pointed out,
most of the neuroblastomas are P53 wild type.
And surprisingly, we still see neuroblastomas as being one of the cancer entities
with the highest prevalence of ecDNA.
And so understanding how those are tolerated,
or the generation of those are tolerated in the context of wild type P53
is a great question. In this population, we don't know the
P53 status, but we assume that it's quite similar to what we know to
be in ecDNA-positive neuroblastomas in general, where
we've assessed this
over hundreds of patients, and we don't see that there's
a higher degree of P3 mutations in this population.
So we don't think that is one of the primary causes of this
difference, and yeah, but much to follow up on.
And I guess another thing that makes maybe neuroblastoma a little bit different
is typically aren't
aneuploidy is associated with a better prognosis to some degree in
neuroblastoma, where diploidy is associated with a poor?
Absolutely. But I think as we also learned yesterday in the training session on
chromosomal instability, I think aneuploidy
is not always associated with ongoing chromosomal instability.
So only because they're aneuploid doesn't mean that they're still chromosomally
unstable. And as I showed you today, we do see that there's actually
no difference of whether or not they're chromosomally unstable in the sense that
they have any type of micronucleus.
The difference that we see clinically is really between those that have
micronucleus with ecDNA in them and not, and we don't actually see a
difference for those patients that have micronuclei that lack ecDNA,
that presumably have chromosome fragments or chromosomes that end up in
micronuclei due to normal chromosomal instability.
Yeah. Thanks a lot.
Thanks, Carol.
Maybe this, the other side.
Thank you, Dr. Hessen. It's really exciting work.
I'm curious whether you think we might be underestimating the
amount of ecDNA in certain cancer types because perhaps
micronucleation has already taken care of those ecDNA and whether there's
anything that we can learn about the mechanism from those specific cancer types.
That's a great question. If you
assessed ecDNA using sequencing, I think
that for those cells that have a micronucleus with ecDNA in them,
presumably you would still be able to detect higher amounts of
oncogene copies in those cells. So I don't think that it would directly impact this
on a global level if you have ecDNA and there are
micronucleation. But it's a great question to ask whether
maybe in the life cycle of a tumor, ecDNA is, that are
maybe not of selective advantage, are there at some point and are lost again maybe
through the process of micronucleation and something that definitely interesting to
study in the future.
Thank you.
So we have seen in the previous talk that there's a lot of clonality when it comes
to ecDNA. Do you see evidence of micronucleation being
clonal or subclonal, more to speak?
Whether micronucleation itself is subclonal?
So as I showed you, I think this is a transient phenomenon.
I think micronuclei can persist over-...
generations, but normally, or more frequently, and we might want to ask
Peter or others who are more expert in micronuclei.
Normally, micronuclei in the cell generations and the
cell divisions after the first one where they're generated often
reincorporate into the main nucleus over time.
So I don't think that it's per se we're able to use micronuclei
to detect whether this is a clonal or subclonal event.
This might be an ongoing event, and at any time at which we look at this,
this just captures the presence of this in the
subpopulation of cells. But for the other cells, we don't know whether or not they
either will
micronucleate or have already in the past.
So I think it's a difficult question to answer.
Thanks. Maybe one last question.
Yeah.
Sorry. Do you think the DNA damage which you
see coming from these micronuclei
is kind of damage which
is still capable of signaling to block the cell growth,
and at the same time is incapable of repair, so it's
becoming
permanent DNA damage, and that could be the reason why?
It's a great question. Actually, also goes to the question from Marcin.
I think many people are wondering whether maybe the damage in the micronucleus is
repaired. You saw these clusters of ecDNA all in the same micronucleus.
You could imagine that if repaired in a certain sense and then coming back into the
primary nucleus, these might be precursors to HSRs, right?
At the same time, I agree with you that the DNA damage itself might be the trigger
that elicits this
effect on cells
of lower cell cycling and maybe DNA
cell death and others. So we haven't investigated this, but that's definitely
something we should do in the future. Thanks a lot.
Okay. So we're now going to, I think we have
a little more time for the general discussion of that session.
We have 10 more minutes. So please feel free to ask more questions if you have,
to all the speakers of today, and also maybe one last
round of applause for you two and for the entire session. Thank you very much.
Any questions? I will actually go back to them.
Hi. Sharda Shakti Kumar from "TGN."
All along you've been talking about ecDNA in human.
Have you ever looked at them in other species, like for example,
canines'
cancers?
I can start by saying that I have definitely not looked at ecDNA in
canines.
I think that we can learn a lot, but if we take the concept of that
question and just expand it out, I think we can learn a lot about really
different
organisms, right? And kind of their approach to chromosome biology.
And so I think that we learn a lot about, for example, from tetrahymena about
telomere biology. And so I think looking at other species could certainly
potentially could teach us a lot.
Thank you.
I have question for Peter,
and I wonder if you know the mechanism for the
transported cargo DNA tethered to the host chromosome.
You mean during the transport itself?
No. So you show that the transported DNA cargo get into the
nucleus while the mitosis happens.
Oh, yes.
And I saw from your image data that this DNA cargo tethered to the
host chromosome.
Yeah. Actually, so in those cases, I don't think they're tethered to chromosomes.
I think they're just normally segregating if they have a centromere.
So we showed that about half of these transferred DNAs do have a
centromere.
Mm-hmm.
So it's suggesting that they can bind to the mitotic spindle.
So they would essentially segregate and align themselves just like any
other chromosome would. Then there's also, on the other hand, there's also another
fraction that doesn't have a centromere.
Mm-hmm.
And those either commonly misalign, and they could form another cycle of
micronucleation.
But currently, we don't have evidence of tethering like
normal ecDNAs normally do. So these are actually
fragments or large pieces of DNA before they've actually
evolved into an ecDNA.
I see. I wanted to ask whether you see some ecDNA
retention element features in the transported cargo. Yeah.
Oh, no. We haven't gotten to that far yet, but that's definitely worth a look later
down the road. Yeah.
Okay. Thank you.
I have question for Professor Li
regarding this...
I'm sorry, I just forgot it. I'm nervous. I'll come back.
Sorry.
No worries.
I completely lost what I wanted to ask.
It's okay. Then I can join in. Hi. Thank you so much. A wonderful session.
I'm Sadaf. I'm from the German Cancer Research Center,
Heidelberg.
And I was wondering, we have heard
a bit on the, like that now we know that there is transfer to
the tumor cells, but have we some evidence
that the ecDNAs, they can be transferred also to the
immune cells, and how ecDNAs have an implication
on the tumor microenvironment in general?
And I'm particularly interested how the
spatial technologies or spatial omics
methods can be used to study these tumor microenvironment
effects.
It's general-
Yeah
... I mean, to everybody.
So to comment on the transfer part.
So we haven't directly looked-- So what
I showed earlier was a mechanism for DNA transfer that eventually gives
rise to an ecDNA-like element.
We haven't directly tested whether ecDNAs themselves transfer,
although, work from Anton suggests that they frequently go
into micronuclei, so perhaps they do, but we haven't directly looked at
that.
Spatial, I'll let Howard take that.
Yeah, I think your question's about really specifically not just transferring
between tumor cells, but actually transferring into, let's
say, immune cells or other cell types, right?
And so I think that we see some kind of that kind of data.
Actually, people have studied, for example, do a rearrange, I think
immune receptor loci, some of those can be transferred, right?
So I would not rule that out.
Okay. All right.
Thank you.
Thanks so much.
We'll go to Marson.
So fascinating session and really exciting data on
retention as a drug target. I was wondering,
and this maybe goes to
Howard's talk as well, is if you can
predict the sort of,
I guess, retention
elements on individual ecDNA across tumors,
does the
stickiness
in patient samples correlate with survival?
I guess some ecDNA might be more intrinsically
retention proficient based on these DNA elements.
I don't know how well they can be predicted if you have a motif
that's
easily
readable. But if in human
tumors, are you seeing a correlation with retention ability and
survival?
I really like where you're going with this direction.
That is, can we think about targeting the ecDNA
retention elements or using it more of a prognostic kind of basis?
I think that the current evidence suggests that the ecDNA we see in
clinical samples are already at the end of a long evolutionary selection
process. So the ecDNA retention element is pretty intact, right?
Because imagine that if every cell division, you have a risk of being
lost. This is a very strong selection pressure.
And so the kind of evidence that we see is that in
fact, we see ecDNA that
retain multiple retention elements, right?
So the COLO 320,
the MYC ecDNA has lots and lots of ecDNA retention elements.
We do see a correlation that
if you start with an area in the genome that start with a lot of
high ecDNA sort of retention element density, then
there's, in fact, an enrichment for those to be
smaller ecDNAs. There's no longer a pressure to rearrange
or co-opt additional elements because you already got everything you need, right,
to just keep getting propagated.
I am not aware of... Let's see. I think the
question you ask is possible. I just wonder that in the clinically observed tumors,
right? So somebody to have a tumor, they have to have
some sort of
billions of tumor cells already. If you have an ecDNA there, that's already
the end of a very long selection process.
So, you may have a harder time tweaking out differences in
retention efficiency in that setting.
But I guess the tumors, Anton, that you were
highlighting that had a very high fraction of these
ecDNA in micronuclei. Did they have a different cis structure?
Maybe those tend to be retained not as efficiently,
and is there something you could detect there?
That's exactly the question we're trying to ask now is to see how...
And this is between different tumors, right?
So between different patients, different tumors.
We would want to know, for example, does the amount of, or the type of
retention element that is situated on these different ecDNA that are structurally
quite heterogeneous, is this different and does that explain why
some tumors have higher micronucleation frequency than others?
Yeah, I'll just hypothesize that your question might be very answerable if we
look at the DNA methylation status of
actually ecDNAs because we learn in the retention element work
that DNA methylation is capable of silencing a retention element
activity. So they might have each have 10 copies, but some of
the copies may have more or less DNA demethylation and
therefore more at the brink of being
lost or not lost.
Okay, let's go to the other side for a question.
Sorry for my blackout. There is this feedback here, and it's very
disturbing. So the question is regarding
your donor cell line, because you only showed that you
use RPE cells for the generation of
the extra
nuclear DNA, which is being transferred to the acceptor
cells. I'm just curious if you tried also different cell lines
as donor cell lines. The reason why I'm asking, because
we did some experiments on RPE cells.
We induced micronuclei in those cells with
replication stress. And when we stained for SIGA
in this particular cell line, we never saw SIGA
colocalization with this micronuclei.
It might be some special
feature of this particular cell line.
So I'm just curious if you tried other cell lines and if this might be
some luck in your hands.
Yes. Oh, sorry. Yeah, so I probably showed
mostly RPE1 data, but we've done this across many different human cell lines
now, and also we're now extending this into mice, mouse cell lines.
But we've seen this in somatic epithelial cells, both cancer,
non-cancer. We've done it also in induced pluripotent stem cells,
fibroblasts. There's a
panel of lines that we've seen this in, and we've measured it in the paper actually
across many different conditions, across many different lines.
So it's not a RPE1 specific match.
The efficiency of the transfer was it
the same across different cell lines or?
Yeah. So, depending on the condition in which you induce DNA damage or
mitotic errors, but it seems that across the board is somewhere between 1% to
4% of micronuclei seems to have evidence of transfer.
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
So although it's low, it's reproducible,
and measurable across many different conditions and cell types.
But we think that more importantly, under different contexts in which those
events then become positively selected for will have the biggest impact.
Yeah.
Okay, thank you.
Unfortunately, we don't have time for more questions, but you can come to us and
ask questions after the session. So I'd like to thank all the speakers of the
session and thank you all for your questions and your attention.